the most recent mass shootings in the
united states have renewed calls for gun
control in america but it's a
complicated issue in part because each
of the 50 states has freedom to enact
gun laws as they see fit making the u.s
a nation of a myriad of often disjointed
firearm laws
every state can do what they want within
the fixed parameters of the constitution
and federal law
that's that is the system and every
state really has the incentive to do
something different
within reason because every state truly
is different but do stronger laws really
mean less gun violence here in the state
of new jersey the answer is yes
according to the giffords law center to
reduce gun violence new jersey has the
second strictest gun laws anywhere in
the united states
and also has some of the lowest gun
death rates
even still governor phil murphy signed
seven new bills into law that tighten
the state's already stringent gun
regulations
new jersey has one of the nation's
lowest rates of gun violence and gun
deaths
there is a reason for that it is because
we are among the leaders in gun safety
state officials are bracing for as many
as 200 000 new gun permit applications
before the new laws go into effect
the challenge with gun policy in america
can also be seen in new jersey because
of its neighboring state pennsylvania
which has much looser gun policy
guns can easily cross state lines
while new jersey can do our best to kind
protect our communities with these
really great common sense gun
legislation unfortunately we're
susceptible because there are places
that people can obtain more freely
in neighboring new york the governor
recently announced anyone applying for a
new gun permit will also have to list
their social media accounts the stronger
the gun laws the lower the gun death
rate but the issue is more complicated
than people on either side of the gun
debate often like to admit gabriel zondo
al jazeera jersey city new jersey